20:19 is gonna be a huge and I mean huge
year for the Backstreet Boys
they will embark on their biggest arena
tour in 18 years it's a second chance
for the guys VSP who for the first time
are revealing to each other the moment
they took they hit their personal rock
bottom I don't think I've ever told you
guys this in this new candid sit-down
they reveal their bond and their
breaking points for AJ McLean it was his
struggle with alcohol addiction me going
to rehab
the first time that was one of the two
most humbling moments for me was that
and having Ava was the next most
humbling moment but now having a child
who doesn't understand doesn't know if
that what it means between being drunk
daddy and sober daddy that really messed
with my head for Nick it was a failed
solo album how he lost a sister to lupus
while for Brian it was his 1998
open-heart surgery you know I had a like
a 22 percent chance that I wouldn't wake
up I mean I delayed my surgery twice so
that we could have two different tours
now stronger than ever they've got their
Vegas residency upcoming DNA album and
world tours but before that they're
celebrating the holidays once you go
home for the holidays we're gonna go to
holiday food and we're gonna be with our
kids and candy
et has been with the boyband throughout
all their ups and downs and during their
25 years together they say right now is
the best time I'm proud of who we are
I'm proud of what we've done telling a
story that's never been told before
living it that's exciting to me look for
a band to be together for 25 years it's
bananas right 25 minutes
wait between us okay let's stick to
music okay please let's do that
[Music]
[Applause]